Gregg it's Ross long time no talk how
are you buddy boss what's happening my
friend so I am so fired up to talk about
these games with you I was just telling
the guys I literally have never had you
on my show and that had you say multiple
things I didn't know didn't realize and
we're of interesting to me so let's just
let's go through them let's start Colts
Texans
give me the most interesting thing about
that game to you I'll say two things one
is called D Texans oh and I think the
Colts have done a really good job in
recent weeks and so when they played the
Texans in the last time week 14 with
pressure concepts we don't think of the
Colts as a high percentage blitz defense
but they've done a really good job with
pressure concepts causing problems not
only for the protection but for deshaun
Watson the second thing I'd say is look
for naheem Heinz as a past receiver for
the Colts they've increased his role in
that regard as the years progressed he's
very very difficult as a matchup player
both in the backfield and detached from
the formation so I got questions on both
these quarterbacks actually as a follow
up number one Shaun Watson he took the
most sacks in the NFL by far yeah do you
think that that is something that he
will continue to improve upon or is that
a red flag that has you really concerned
my guess is he'll continue to improve
because I think the some of the reasons
for that are fixable and correctable I
think that his tendency to hold the ball
too long is correctable and I think his
understanding of where pressures coming
from is correctable he struggles with
both of those things right now as for
Andrew Luck is he a different player
than he was before and if so how before
the injury yes I think he's different
because of the nature of the athletes
and how he's being coached he's now a
much more rhythmic player the ball comes
out that's part of the a sense of design
that's intentional so you don't see him
holding the ball as long you don't see
as many secondary action plays which are
a function of the fact that the design
of the offense presents quicker define
reads and throws
all right let's move on to Saturday
night Cowboys and the Seahawks what's
the most interesting aspect of this
matchup behind the scenes I would say
from a profile perspective both teams
are somewhat similar I think they want
to run the football they do it a little
bit differently the Seahawks do it out
of shotgun inside zone we know what the
Cowboys do with Zeke it's a very
multiple run game I think both
quarterbacks have secondary
actionability and I think both teams are
rely on that and particularly in
critical longer yardage situations I
would say that two things are factors in
this game the Seahawks pass protection
could be an issue they've got some
injuries along the old line they've had
to make some changes and adjustments and
I think the Cowboys are very very good
with their pass rush and then I think
for the Cowboys offense to player stand
out to me that are critical Cole Beasley
we know about but the player who got
some snaps this past week against the
Giants and I think can become important
as a drive sustainer is Tavon Austin if
you would have told me a couple years
ago that in 2019 I'd be hosting the Dan
Patrick show and Greg Cassell would say
Tavon Austin is important in a playoff
game I would not have believed you
that's unbelievable
is it too simplistic Greg for me to say
I think this is a close low-scoring game
and as a result I'm gonna go with
Russell Wilson and the Seahawks because
he comes through in the clutch and dak
doesn't I know that's overly simplistic
right but when you watch the tape Greg
do you feel like you can see experience
I know it's tough because you're just
watching video tape but did you feel
like you can see guys that are more
comfortable late in games than others I
don't want to answer that yes because I
think I'd be just making that up but I
think that what you're saying is the way
the teams are built to a certain extent
when you're going to run the ball and
play good defense the expectation more
often than not is that the games will be
lower scoring and and therefore closer I
think that the Seahawks feel very good
about Russell Wilson's ability not only
to connect on shot plays off their run
action but in his second reaction
ability just look what he did last week
had lock-it to set them up for a field
goal he's done that quite a bit this
year obviously Prescott made that great
throw last week at the end of the game
but I think that overall the seahawks
feel very comfortable with their profile
the Cowboys have been very inconsistent
in that regard so my guess is they feel
less comfortable I think I saw a stat I
can't remember what it was
Russell Wilson either was the only guy
that didn't miss a snap this year or
hasn't missed a snap in seven years
which given his style is just insane I
just can't believe he has not missed a
game yet let's get to the Sunday one
o'clock game I don't picture that being
the case with Lamar Jackson I think he's
actually had to come out of a couple of
games this year
here's what intrigues me about this one
Greg it's tough to stop this
Ravens rushing attack especially because
you're not familiar with it you're not
used to a lot of the concepts they're
using the Chargers just played them to
Greg oh how much do you think that that
helps them Greg I think it does help and
I think that the Ravens have some
distinct profiles in their run game they
line up in pistol when Edwards is in the
game they tend to run a lot of dive
action because he's a straight line kind
of linear runner when Kenneth Dixon is
in the game in the pistol they tend to
run more gap scheme runs I think they
have a distinct profile Jackson is
obviously very difficult to defend in
the run game you can't play with to say
two deep safeties you need to get that
extra player in the box to get that
extra gap they're a dime defense the
chargers which gives them more
athleticism on the field
Jackson obviously has concerns as a
passer at this point he's a lot of
throws on the field he doesn't see the
field particularly well right now and
he's very scattered shot so there's a
balance there and I think their defense
is what really helps them play the way
they do and I know you were at that
first matchup which was just a couple of
weeks ago and they really caused some
problems and passed protection for the
Chargers and that to me is a little bit
of a concern for the Chargers overall
this game for sure but I think their ol
line is a little bit of a concern rivers
can often compensate for that but there
are some times he can't and if I were
the Chargers I would
with empty sets I'd go no huddle I
define everything for Phillip as quickly
as possible
and I'd make it difficult for the Ravens
to show their blitzes you know what I
think that's a really good point Greg
because they ran a middle linebacker
defensive tackle stunts
a number of times and they killed him
the Chargers never adjust it to it and
that to me great deal you know that it's
a hard deal it's it's very hard but also
in pro football
Greg and you know this if they do it
once and it works they're definitely
gonna do it again so when you go off to
the side you guys say hey look when that
middle linebackers walked up he's gonna
try to pick the running backs had to
come up and stone him right there on the
line of scrimmage the guard has to be
expecting the contact and be willing to
accept it from the middle I mean it just
it seemed like they were surprised by it
every time Greg yeah and I'm not gonna
dispute what you said you know you know
better than I being on a sideline and
discussing it but I think that's a tough
deal because when you sort of get that
that linebacker up in the a gap like
that the back obviously is going to
respond to him but then when you do
those those picks it is really difficult
for a guard or a senator so it's I'm
anxious to see how they respond to it
this week so you talked about Lamar
Jackson just the last thing on him
did you see enough progress the last few
weeks to be bullish on what he can do in
the postseason and moving forward in the
next year in his career well no I think
to be honest with you I think you got it
with him he's not at that point yet he
needs an offseason now he's not a very
good passer it comes down to this
conversation about balance can you run
this offense can you truly have an
offense with a quarterback who runs as
much as he does
my answer to that would be no but I
think that doesn't matter right now
you're playing this out for this season
they want to win a Super Bowl I don't
think he can do this over the course of
a long career he's going to have to
become a better passer talk with my
buddy Greg Cosell in his office at NFL
Films executive producer of the NFL
matchup show Greg can you confirm that
your office is still not in the basement
no it's not
actually the decent-sized screen here on
switch is nice yeah okay cuz fritzy
fritzy in his head said well Greg Greg's
been watching film in his basement at
NFL Films for 40 years Fitch fritzy was
convinced that you can only watch film
in a basement no no it's a real office
it's actually not as big as maybe some
people might think it's actually pretty
small but you know I have what I need
you know I'm a simple man right so let's
get into the Eagles in the Bears
I got a telly Greg I've been skeptical
of true Biscay all year the last couple
games a lot of the throws he's made some
of the third down conversions yeah I
start he's starting to win me over Greg
well that's critical so you just sit on
what's critical third down now there are
fence is we obviously it's a very
interesting mix of Matt naggy trying to
do a lot of a lot of things you know
cool schemes and different concepts but
then it's also a mix of a very simple
basic concepts to help the Biscay at
this point in his development one thing
that really stands out on film when you
watch them is how well and consistently
they work to the boundary to the short
side of the field because that defines
the reads very often it's just two men
route concepts and combinations to the
boundary and tarik Cohen is almost
always one of those boundary receivers
and he's a very difficult matchup he is
so fun to watch I'm gonna miss Darren
Sproles whenever he retires
I think Tariq Cohen Greg might be my new
Darren Sproles well yeah he's very
similar it's interesting both guys are
playing in this game and you're going to
see similar concepts from both teams and
in the pass game both players line up to
the boundary and both players cause
problems for man coverage because a lot
of the way the NFL has evolved in terms
of coverage is even if you're playing a
zone concept most teams will man up to
the short side of the field and both
Tirico and and Darren Sproles caused
problems in the past game whether
they're offset in the backfield or
whether they're detached from the
formation all right so Greg we've got a
poll question and I'm just curious the
poll question is the team playing this
weekend that we think has the least
chance to go on a run but you're not
gonna really ask me that
I'll give you the opposite Greg I'll
give you the opposite who's playing this
weekend that based on your videotape
study throughout the year well which
which of these teams you think is best
prepared to kind of make a run here over
these next two or three games well I'm
really bad at this but I'm gonna give
you an answer but I'm really bad at this
because I can give you five reasons you
know either way you know that right from
watching tape particularly when teams
have definable strengths and weaknesses
I'm never surprised when a weakness or a
flaw shows up in a playoff right but the
team that I'm most fascinated with as we
head to the playoffs are the
Indianapolis Colts wow that is really uh
nice in here telling you to go into the
Superbowl but I I think I already put it
on Twitter Greg Kochi okay but I think
that there Dee coordinator Maddie Bruce
has done an outstanding job with what
most people would say is not high level
talent with his schemes his concepts a
ton of what we call gap exchange on the
defensive line you know all about that
and how difficult that can be for
offensive linemen to deal with and and I
think he's really done a good job now
they could stop at some point just
because of the talent but I I really
like the Colts Greg I really like
getting a chance to talk with you thank
you so much for the time as always
appreciate arras thanks for having me
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]